all right well first of all it is nice
to see all of you together
thank you thank you thank you thanks for
having us
so first of all you know this podcast
has been going on for over
a half a year now um what what have you
guys learned about yourself but also
each other through this process
oh jeff i've learned a lot of dirty
secrets about these guys
no um yeah look obviously when this
whole thing
started it started around you know
when cheryl and i were doing dancing
with the stars
um so a lot of the guests a lot of the
you know
kind of foreground was based around that
and we had some other guests
in between you know other other
contestants that were on the show
but then after the show was done i feel
like is when we really kind of got into
our groove
and really started diving into what this
podcast is really about
yeah which is mental health recovery
living life on life's terms
and you know battling back from
addiction
and whatnot and really
really kind of finding your your self
and your own true happiness and i think
we've learned a lot about each other
whether it's through having guests on
the show or just when it's
you know just us three uh talking to
each other
um really getting to kind of dive into
each other's backstory
and um you know where we are now where
we were then
how many parallels that we all have
because we've all
crashed and burned and we've made it out
the other end so
yeah there's a lot of parallels amongst
us three even though it's three
kind of different generations really
that's what makes it so cool though i
think is the different generations you
know like we've all experienced the same
thing but at different times and
a different time in the world that we
live in today for sure and um
i think uh go ahead aj what do you want
to fish no
no i mean that's i mean look i think we
really found
found our groove now and i think you
know now's
now is when things are really getting
meaty and really getting good
down and dirty mm-hmm yeah
i've known aj for uh over 20 years
and i thought i'd heard it all and i
found out that
he puts on sock shoe
socks like two weeks ago
it's still blowing and then he's hours
doesn't have socks on i mean
every time i put my socks on i think
about you aj
do you want oh you want me to clarify
wait did i hear socks
on in the shower yes sometimes yeah
sometimes
well look i number one i i
hate feet feet are gross okay
um in my own opinion feet are meant to
be covered by socks and shoes at all
times unless you're in the water
and even then sometimes but look i've
been doing what i do for a living for
for
over 30 years yeah and ironically
i have the softest feet of anyone i know
and i and i attribute a lot of that to
always wearing socks
even in this shower i don't even have
any i've never had a callus
on my foot ever not even when you were
dancing that's hard to believe
no never we were asked a question
we do we do sock sock shoe
shoe and of course everyone in the world
says
sock sock shoe shoe and then aj says he
puts on one sock
then one shoe then one sock in another
shoe
and i don't understand that okay so i
think on the next
episode of the podcast we should have a
therapist on
we've had plenty we've had plenty and
okay
sometimes you just can't get rid of the
sock shoe sock shoe you know
exactly you guys have been very open on
this podcast
especially with your struggle struggles
and you know past with addictions and
whatnot
you know why do you feel it's so
important to be open about that
well i think it's you know for my
personal experience
it has been very therapeutic being able
to talk about my own story
and to be able to kind of uh talk to
also
my coach my co-hosts because like
honestly i think if it wasn't for them
for instance for example i wouldn't have
tried to make
amends maybe with iron you know and i
think it was really important that
um you know i was open at that time and
i felt like it was time and
they just validated everything for me
and i think that all has to do like
everything we talk about on this podcast
all has to do with our own struggles of
mental health because all we can really
do is talk about our own stories
um in our own personal experience we
can't really we're not certified
therapists or licensed therapists you
know and at the end of the day we have
guests like that come on
um and i just i it's like a full-on
therapy session every time we finish
shooting or recording a podcast and it's
been so
nice to not be edited for me at least um
you know i come from dancing with the
stars and it's very
abc disney friendly and it's nice just
to be able to talk freely
about like real and raw emotions that
do affect not just me but a majority of
our population who may not have
the courage yet to speak about it so
hopefully you know through us
they'll be able to at least relate and
start the conversation
yeah oh no i was gonna just attack on to
that that
speaking about addiction and as you know
having
gone through it and survived it it
addiction is a disease of loneliness you
think you're the only one in the world
right
and so the feedback we've gotten from
people when we share
our stories with kimono open warts and
all
it's like wow i've i've
started you know i've gotten sober i
used to think
like i was so different and hearing you
guys talk so openly about it let
me feel less ashamed so that's what to
your question that
i think is one of the big motivations
for doing this show
is to be able to let people know you're
not a bad
person you know we we struggled the same
way and we found the
the other way out and so yeah people
have been
um writing to saying i i've decided to
get sober i heard you guys story and so
if nothing else
i love that oh my goodness um i know
that earlier this month you guys talked
about how
you didn't agree with demi lovato's use
of california sober
respectfully and what was the reaction
you received discussing that topic did
you hear
from demi or anybody did not hear from
anybody on her side but i know
um from from what i've seen from a lot
of our listeners
is you know look you're gonna have
mixed feelings about a lot of things i
mean
you know nine times out of ten a lot of
people don't always agree
and everyone's got opinions um and
you know from what i've seen from a lot
of our listeners it's
it's leaning more towards disagreeing
um but there are some that are like you
know
that's her choice that's her path and i
completely respect that we all do and i
completely agree
everyone has a different journey um and
we're all trying to get to the same
ending point which is to stay sober and
to you know stay alive kind of just
basically get rid of our demons and to
and to live our best life yeah but again
you know like cheryl said we're not
doctors we're not shrinks
we don't you know we're just we're just
trying to
basically say look that doesn't work for
us it never had
it doesn't it never will we've tried it
because yeah we've tried it all
right for sure yeah and it just doesn't
work
and it's our own personal experience you
know exactly
and look i we we all wish her the best
and you know if this works for her
great but most most
people that have tried similar
approaches to getting sober that we've
seen in their rooms
of aaa and all the other a's for the for
for 20 plus years it just doesn't work
and also she has such a strong influence
you know so i think that's why we were
so passionate about it for all
like the sober community in general i
think sometimes just depends on where
you are in your life there's not there's
days where sometimes i may not be as
strong as other days you know and
if she has such a huge influence it's
just good to kind of see
the other side just so people can see
both sides to the story you know
and and i was going to say it's like
again because
our circles are circles of people that
have gotten sober that have survived
addiction right
that have tried it all including myself
including
everybody here and and the thing is
every wish of an addict
is i want to stop getting high but i
still want to be able to get high
yeah that's right or still being able to
drink or whatever it is yeah yeah
right right um aj you just released a
new song
love song love um can you just talk to
us about the importance of the song
and music video because it's very
meaningful
yes well uh thank you um so
the song love song love uh when it got
presented to me
from a very dear friend of mine
amazingly talented producer and
songwriter mitch allen
um first thing i said was okay we gotta
cut it
this is a smash the song is so happy
everyone's been living in like solitude
and darkness
and like you know things are starting to
come back to life
and the new normal is starting to happen
and we're moving in the right direction
but still people need
hope people need positivity and
so that was the first kind of knee-jerk
reaction i had when i first
cut the song was this is a happy song
this is a summer song a spring song
it's it's happy it's uplifting and then
i really started listening to the
lyrical content
and i was like you know me myself
being a huge advocate for the lgbt
community which i have been for years
um you know it just kind of set off a
light bulb in my head
that to me the song you know love strong
love is
is that perfect love everybody wants
that
storybook love that fantasy book love
they want that
disney ending of the movie love they
want that love song love
and not only with with another person
but with themselves um and
so when i approached renee who is my
partner in crime
is as far as directing and the video
treatment
when him and i were in my car first
thing he said when he
heard it was he goes dude check out this
one place
in l.a called the doll house which is
where we shot
and it's just literally it's like
barbie's dream house on steroids
and i was like dude this is amazing
then the conversation continued talking
about
getting a couple of you know women in
the video maybe models
and i took it one step further and said
okay
we can do that but i want to find two
transgender women uh to be in the video
and to help spread the message of
love acceptance tolerance equality and
not only loving each other but loving
yourself
and being proud of the person you are
though i tell you slightly different
story
the second you saw it you immediately
said
i want two transgender girls i don't
know you said
we're thinking about girl you never even
discussed other girls
so i just want to clarify the second he
was like
we gotta have two transgender girls and
we and we got
so lucky with two amazing girls
nala wild and carmen carrera both
transgender women
um very prominent in the transgender
community
very strong um we just had her on as a
guest
yes i mean very very very passionate
about
the community um and you know i've said
this before and i'll stress it again
here
uh you know everyone please go watch the
video
but watch it in its entirety post
credits
i call it my marvel ending because after
every marvel movie there's
there's a little bonus watch it all the
way post credits there
is amazing uh diary moments between both
ladies and you can see where you can
learn
about the lgbtq community where you can
donate
to different charitable causes um you
know
so i'm super proud of it and this is
just proud of you guys it was so good it
was really good
thank you sure i watched it a few times
i have to say
even though i co-directed it with aj the
first time i saw it all the way through
with the girls testimonials at the end i
started crying i'm like how are you
going to cry you worked on this thing
though
my wife did too my wife she's like wow
that's incredible i'm like thank you
babe when you
see two human beings they're two human
beings that want to be loved just like
everybody else
and and seeing it through you guys
having fun in the music video and all
that but
just to see them as human beings it just
made me cry
and it tripped me up because i was like
we've been editing this we shot yeah
it's like
i was there exactly it was really good
and her interview was great too
so this is the last i think this is the
last one that was aired
yeah yeah so obviously aj and cheryl you
guys were on
dancing with the stars last season um so
out of forever
yeah forever ago out of the three
remaining backstreet boys
okay which one would you like to see on
the show
next kevin i would say kevin yeah
because kevin actually
look here's the thing uh and i'm not
gonna name any names because that's just
not the person i am
but i will say you know some people that
i've seen on the
show that may say they don't have dance
experience clearly do
and then and then there are others that
have never
danced in their life yeah um and i will
say
even though i've been dancing my entire
life it was still a challenge because
i've never danced
anything like what i did with cheryl
you've never been all right
i'm glad that i learned because now like
i could kind of tuck that in my back
pocket i've got that ready to go
whenever i need it you know oh really
let me see your cha-cha
i am comfortably sitting right now and i
worked out today it was like
no but kevin kevin for sure would be my
first pick kevin actually used to teach
ballroom
wait don't say that now dina's never
gonna put them enough you just
no no yeah but not on the level of
like you or artem or anybody else he
wasn't like a professional ballroom
dancer he just taught like an arthur
murray
yes yes basically at arthur murray is
basically kind of what he
has to like to test or something but
yeah but still
i think he would do fantastic and he is
he is really really graceful when it
comes to that style of dancing
and you think that i'd be a good partner
for him for some reason i think you
would
i would be really interested because
you're both i think they'll give me
another backstreet boy
you're both very you're both very
strong-minded and strong-willed
so it would also make for great
television